JESSE WATTERS AND DANA PERINO.
A MASS SHOOTING, THIS TIME IN
THOUSAND OAKS, CALIFORNIA, 12
DEAD INCLUDING A POLICE OFFICER,
RON HELUS, WHO GAVE HIS LIFE FOR
OTHERS.
HERE ARE HIS FELLOW OFFICERS
PAYING RESPECT TO THEIR FALLEN
BROTHER ON THE 101.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF IDEAS
WHEN IT COMES TO PREVENTING SUCH
HORROR.
THE PROBLEM IS THE LOUDEST
VOICES ONLY OFFERED TWO CHOICES.
IT'S EITHER YOU WANT MORE GUN
CONTROL OR YOU WANT TO ARM
EVERYONE.
WE NEED TO ESCAPE THIS PRISON OF
TWO IDEAS.
HERE'S HOW.
WE NEED A SYSTEM THAT WORKS.
WE ONCE HAD A PROCESS FOR
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO HAD A
KNOWN MENTAL ILLNESS BUT THE
PROCESS IS NOW PARALYZED BY
FEAR.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE PEGGED
AS VIOLATING SOMEONE ELSE'S
RIGHTS.
TODAY PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS
HOUSE LESS THAN ONE-TENTH OF THE
PEOPLE THEY DID IN THE 1950s.
YET OUR POPULATION HAS DOUBLED.
IF WE CAN HOUSE THEM, THEN AT
LEAST TAKE THEM TO THEY CAN'T
GET A GUN.
THE SHOOTER TERRIFIED HIS MOM.
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL A RED FLAG.
TWO, WE NEED AN INDUSTRY FOCUSED
ON HARDENING SOFT TARGETS.
A SHOOTER'S BODY COUNT IS
LIMITED BY THE TIME IT TAKES FOR
A SECOND WEAPON TO ARRIVE.
ENHANCED SECURITY CAN ONLY
REDUCE THAT TIME.
THREE, FINALLY THE MEDIA MUST
LIMIT THE PERSUASIVE POWER OF
ITS COVERAGE.
STUDIES OF SUICIDES VERIFY THE
CAP
CAPI
-- CRIMINAL HOMICIDE HAS A
PAYOFF, IT'S OFTEN REVENGE
OR PROFIT.
THIS IS THE ONLY TERROR THAT
EXISTS AS AN END IN ITSELF.
WE CAN STOP IT BUT TO DO THAT,
WE NEED TO OPEN OURSELVES UP TO
UNCOMFORTABLE IDEAS, ONES THAT
TAKE US OUT OF OUR RIGID IDEAS.
DANA, YOU SEE REOCCURRING
RED FLAGS IN THESE CASES THAT
ARE KIND OF INFURIATING BUT YOU
KNOW IT'S HARD TO FIND A NEEDLE
IN A HAYSTACK.
WHEN THE MOTHER IS TERRIFIED,
WHEN THE PERSON HAS BEEN VISITED
BY EXPERTS BECAUSE OF
PSYCHIATRIC PROBLEMS, YOU GOT TO
ASK YOURSELF HOW COULD THIS
HAPPEN.
>> Dana: THE SYNAGOGUE
SHOOTING, THAT SHOOTER WAS A
RADICALIZED ANTI-SEMITE, EVIL
PERSON.
WAS HE MENTALLY ILL AS WELL?
I DON'T KNOW.
FOR THIS INDIVIDUAL, DEPUTIES
WERE CALLED TO THE HOUSE BECAUSE
THE MOTHER WAS WORRIED.
THE DEPUTY SAY I THINK WE SHOULD
CALL IN, FOLLOWING PROCEDURE,
THE PSYCHIATRIST TO COME IN AND
DO AN EVALUATION.
THEY COME, THEY DO THE
EVALUATION TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY AND THEY SAY OUR
PROFESSIONAL OPINION IS THAT
HE'S NOT A HARM TO HIMSELF OR TO
OTHERS AT THIS TIME.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Dana: THERE IS HUMAN ERROR
THAT'S GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN
THIS AND WE ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE
OF LIBERTY IN THIS COUNTRY.
HOW DO WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL
WITH THIS?
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS THE THORNY PROBLEM.
WE DON'T SEEM TO EVER ACTUALLY
GET PAST TALKING ABOUT IT BEING
A THORNY PROBLEM.
>> Greg: JESSE, IT'S THE OKAY,
IF PEOPLE SAY WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT GUNS, THEN
PEOPLE SAY NO, MORE GUN CONTROL.
IF YOU SAY I THINK WE NEED MORE
SELF-DEFENSE, THEY SAY YOU JUST
WANT TO ARM EVERYONE WITH GUNS.
THERE'S A PLACE SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE THAT COULD SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: MR. POLLOCK IN
PARKLAND, HE TWEETED ALONG THE
LINES THAT YOU'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, DON'T RUSH TO TAKE
EVERYONE'S GUNS AWAY.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT MENTAL
HEALTH.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT SECURITY AND
HAVE TO LOOK AT SOFT TARGETS,
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE STRICTEST GUN CONTROL
STATES OUT THERE.
THE CITY, THIRD SAFEST CITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
IF THIS COULD HAPPEN THERE, IT
COULD HAPPEN ANYWHERE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT DANA WAS
SAYING, IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
POLICE CONTACTS AT THE HOUSE,
NEIGHBORS AND ARE CONCERNED,
LAW ENFORCEMENT CONCERNED THAT
HE WAS TERRORIZING HIS MOTHER,
TERRORIZING HIMSELF.
POSSIBLY HARMING HIMSELF, ONE
NEIGHBOR SAYS, THOUGHTS OF PTSD
INVOLVED.
IF YOU GO AND SEND THE SCHEDULE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
CHECKS THE BOX, IT'S SIMILAR TO
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PARKLAND
SHOOTER.
THIS GUY, HE'S OFF THE CHARTS
INSANE AND THEY GIVE HIM A CLEAN
BILL OF HEALTH.
THESE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, I'M NOT BLAMING
THEM BUT THEY HAVE TO ADDRESS
THE MODALITIES THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH WHEN THEY SEE IS THIS
PERSON A THREAT?
THEY ARE LETTING OFF A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT THEN GO OUT AND
SHOOT PEOPLE.
WE HAVE THIS GUY, HE WAS A
MACHINE GUNNER IN AFGHANISTAN.
HE SAW SOME NASTY STUFF.
PROBABLY HAS DONE SOME NASTY
STUFF.
MAYBE YOU GET A GUY LIKE THIS,
IF HE'S REALLY SEEN A LOT OF
ACTION, AND HE'S ALREADY A
LONER.
WE KNEW THAT.
DIVORCE, LIVING WITH HIS MOM,
NOT A GREAT MATRIX.
MAYBE THERE'S A MANDATORY MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO AT THE VA EVERY SINGLE
YEAR IF YOU HAVE A PROFILE LIKE
THIS.
YOU GO IN, THEY CHECK YOU OUT,
THEY ADDRESS YOUR MENTAL
CAPACITIES, AND THEN MAYBE THEY
CAN SIGN OFF ON SOMETHING.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S TOO MANY
PEOPLE SLIPPING THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
>> Dana: I THINK THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY IS CONCERNED ABOUT
TAKING PEOPLE THAT PTSD WITH
VIOLENCE LIKE THIS, FOR GOOD
REASON.
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT LENGTH.
THERE COULD BE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS FROM BEFORE.
ALSO THERE'S ALREADY A STIGMA
ENOUGH IF YOU HAVE PTSD IN TERMS
OF GETTING TREATMENT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE SHOULDN'T
TALK ABOUT.
>> Jesse: MAYBE YOU DON'T TAKE
HIS GUN AWAY.
MAYBE YOU PUT THEM IN SOME SORT
OF PROGRAM OR HE CAN TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES MAY BEGET MEDICATED
OR ANYTHING THEY COULD HELP
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Dagen: CAN I POINT OUT, TO
YOUR POINT, JESSE, THE GUN LAWS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE STRICTEST.
THERE ARE LAWS ON THE BOOKS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS MAN'S FAMILY
AND ANY PERSON'S TO DEAL WITH
THIS AND GET A GUN OR GUNS OUT
OF THE HANDS OF SOMEONE WHO'S A
THREAT TO THEMSELVES OR OTHER
PEOPLE.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS TO DO
THAT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONE, IF A PERSON IS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY, EVALUATED BY MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS, AND
ADMITTED TO ACCOUNTING MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITY BECAUSE THAT
PERSON WAS FOUND TO BE A DANGER
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS, IT'S
GENERALLY PROHIBITED FROM
POSSESSING OR ACQUIRING FIREARMS
FOR FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
THE FIRST INTRODUCED GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS FOUR
YEARS AGO TO GIVE A LEGAL PATH
OF FAMILY MEMBERS AND EVEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO GET
A GUN OUT OF SOMEBODY'S HANDS.
THIS HAS BEEN THE CASE WITH
POTENTIAL SUICIDE OR VIOLENCE TO
OTHERS, BUT THERE ARE MECHANISMS
IN PLACE THAT IN THIS CASE WERE
NOT USED.
>> Greg: I HAD NO IDEA THAT
WAS ALREADY IN PLACE.
>> Juan: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THE TOP OF YOUR MONOLOGUE WHICH
WAS THAT WE GET LOCKED IN A BOX
IN TERMS OF CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE EITHER SAY NO GUN
CONTROL OR GUN CONTROL.
I WANT TO ALSO POINT OUT, AS
DANA SAID, THIS MAN HAD BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND FOUND NOT TO
BE A THREAT TO HIMSELF OR
OTHERS.
IT'S NOT THE CASE THAT THERE
HADN'T BEEN ATTENTION.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO SAY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MENTAL ILLNESS
ARE NOT OF A RATER PROCLIVITY TO
COMMIT GUN VIOLENCE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE BETWEEN GUN
VIOLENCE AND MENTAL ILLNESS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
TIMMY WAS IMPORTANT IS WE
ACKNOWLEDGE WE HAVE TOO MANY
GUNS.
IT MAKES FOR A PROBLEM NOT ONLY
FOR GUN VIOLENCE OR SUICIDE, THE
OTHER THING I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THERE ARE POINTS
WHERE WE CAN AGREE AS AMERICANS.
I WISH WE WOULD GET TO THAT.
IT'S OVERWHELMING.
IF YOU ASK AMERICANS ABOUT
BACKGROUND CHECKS, UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS, AMERICANS SAY
ASKED, INCLUDING GUN OWNERS, NRA
MEMBERS THAT YES, THAT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
LET'S DO IT.
LET'S HAVE A WAITING PERIOD FOR
PEOPLE TO GET GUNS.
>> Greg: HE GOT THIS GUN
LEGALLY.
I'M SURE THERE WAS A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
>> Juan: IN THIS CASE, I'M
SURE THERE WAS.
BUT AS DANA SAID, HE WAS
INTERVIEWED BY MENTAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS WHO DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE MINIMIZED AS A PUT THIS
GUY AWAY OR DENY HIM ACCESS.
THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT IF
SOMEONE IS FOUND TO BE ABUSIVE
OF THEIR SPOUSE OR MOM IN THIS
CASE, THEY SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO HAVE A GUN.
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS,
ASSAULT WEAPONS, AND IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SENSE
THAT HOW MANY GUNS CAN ANY ONE
PERSON HAVING THE COUNTRY?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Dana: IT ONLY TAKES ONE.
>> Dagen: I WANTED TO SAY
FAMILIES IN THAT STATE AND MANY
OTHER STATES, INCREASING NUMBER
INCLUDING FLORIDA, AFTER THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING EARLIER THIS
YEAR, IF YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
AND YOUR FAMILY WHO HAS A GUN OR
GUNS AND THERE'S A PATH LEGALLY
TO GET THAT GUN OUT OF THEIR
HANDS IF YOU THINK THEY ARE A
VIOLENT THREAT.
>> Greg: RIGHT, OKAY.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER EVERY DAY
THE DANGERS THAT THE POLICE
INDOOR, THIS IS WHAT THEY DO FOR